three months and 18 days that was a draw
but magnus at some point outplaying
kasparov in that game do you know how
old abhimani mishra is today
the exact same
almost he is only three days younger
than magnus was at that time i guess
what opening it is i was gonna say it's
bad news you know what was the highest
scoring um opening
this one the slime was the slouch
no one's told him about the statistics
maybe we should have released it before
to all the players and gone here you go
and uh magnus meanwhile he's chosen a
kind of rare branch of the slav um white
has temporarily temporarily given up a
pawn but white is about to get the
bishop pair so white's knight has gone
to the edge of the board and is going to
take off the black light square bishop
and once that happens black will be a
bit vulnerable on the light squares
black's gonna have a bit of a weird uh
wrecked pawn structure
it just depends uh on how good ab
emmanuel mitchell's opening homework is
we know that he uses chesapore all the
time thousands of hours clocked on
chesable
and uh he is a bit of an opening expert
yesterday getting some great positions
out of the opening mishra so i'm sure he
knows what he's doing despite the stats
that we saw of the slav defense and okay
current position black is a pawn up but
black has two sets of double pawns on
the c file and the f file
yeah i'm slightly worried i've seen
magnus win positions very similar to
this
he's happy to be a pawn down quite often
these days magnus after being influenced
by
alpha zero and other
kind of ai programs but uh yeah it's
early days let's see do you like this
opening choice simon
for mishra um
yeah i mean i i think when when you're
this age you can sort of play anything
can't you just got to know it reasonably
well and i'm sure
the speed that he's moving he's done a
lot of work on this um i like the way
he's unbalanced it um when you're
playing the world champion if you want
to win as we saw prague during the last
game even though it's a blunder i'm
balancing the situation seems to be a
good choice because if you play if you
play a standard position against magnus
you're probably going to get outplayed
so at least he's got some sort of uh
strange structure and we see magnus has
now
won the pawn back
but black has very good control of
central squares with his knights coming
into those squares
saying that white's very solid as well i
mean white doesn't have any weaknesses
has the two bishops so i would imagine
both sides pretty happy at this stage of
the game look at that phase from magnus
yeah magnus either not impressed by what
mishra is doing or just surprised with
what misha is doing
mishra clearly he's in his homework he's
gained time up to this point he's played
every move instantly as black so
i doubt that uh i doubt that there's
anything too wrong with how black is
playing the game but magnus surprised
and now needs to react by moving white's
light squared bishop again it's under
attack by one of the black knights so
that white light square bishop is going
to take a step back
and magnus playing the most popular move
in my database and uh well i remind you
now playing something that's second
choice
um it's much more popular to develop the
dark square bishop
but uh here
it's a little bit interesting um
the highest rated players to have played
this been wesley soh and sam shankland
and they played it in the opera euro
rapid in 2021. so two very strong
american players mishra himself
from the us maybe he studied those games
i know that sam shankland is a big
adherent of the slav defense so
maybe mishra has been kind of following
uh learning from his
kind of opening setups
in fact sam of course producing a
chessable course on the semi-slav
okay white's bishop meanwhile the dark
squared bishop just developing one
square i think magnus is reluctant to
commit the white king if white's king
had gone to the king side to the right
side of the board too soon then that
might have signaled an attack and uh we
know now that magnus doesn't want to be
under under the attack from these young
players uh mishra would love to throw
pawns forward towards the white king so
both kings just staying flexible for now
kind of it's a waiting game a guessing
game which side will the kings go
and maybe abhimanyu has been working on
sam shanklin's his fellow americans
chestable chorus on the semislav that is
a very popular chesable course and of
course
we know the slav
it's definitely very successful for
white on the tour
but
that must mean that white the player is
playing this with white has studied the
slav for black and no know where the
slav can go wrong for black basically
yeah i mean it's a very solid opening
for black it's often a part of players
repertoires when they're quite young so
they'll know
how to set up as black it's quite
instinctive usually what black does and
therefore if you know what black's ideas
are maybe that's why the top players
they kind of know what uh will make
black the most uncomfortable
okay black's bishop just developing
there and
still early days yeah and i have to say
you know i've been reading a lot of the
answers to our quiz of the day where
we're asking what is the most
what opening move annoys you the most
and a lot of people actually not
responding with this love they're
actually saying you know like jmr18
saying that they find the modern defense
the most annoying
it
immediately destroys my hopes of playing
what i know with white
i think that's the thing isn't it it's
often a psychological game at the start
i mean whatever level you're at even if
you're just starting to play chess or if
you're like grandmaster if your opponent
surprises you um in some position it's
very uncomfortable you're like oh no i i
didn't look at that chessboard course
why didn't i look about why didn't i
look it out in the morning and it could
really throw you off guard so the
element of surprise i think is so so
important uh when you're playing as well
even if you play a slightly inferior
idea if it surprises your opponent can
have maximum
effect
yeah and i have to say um i do also have
to share with you one response i really
liked which is from blank who says that
they get annoyed when
they face d4 when playing black
answered by their son
we all have our like nightmare opponents
and sometimes it's your nearest and
dearest
and keep those answers coming
great you have a chance to win a
fantastic chess ball course and as
always you can tweet your answer using
the hashtag chess champs yeah and that
course by david anton is worth 220
dollars so it's a very big value price
that you can win if you tweet us
magnus is uh thinking yes simon i was
just wondering yeah as you had a lot of
experience in prisons as well like
watching the play what's the most
popular opinions in prisons is it e4
um is it like london systems i mean do
they have anything in particular it's e4
you know they like to attack uh no
surprises there's no link with you know
people being in prison and attacking but
they just they just like to attack and
of course these symbols as anybody knows
whatever level we might be it's harder
to play against the people that are off
the wall and play these spurious
openings and weird gambits and things
it's really hard so i would play slavs
and things that i know the territory or
french
but i would say in this position here if
i made it if you know the millions of
club players if i looked at this and
said well where are the imbalances if
you were black what were you looking at
you know and
if you were white and you played that
pawn to g3 early on you might think well
a bishop will be going to g2 fiance but
it's not here you've played that pawn
and you've weakened squares on f3 g2 and
h3
if that king were to castle and just at
my level if you like that's where i
would look to target and think you know
if you castle you're giving me your
address you give me your address and i'm
going to send the boys around and the
girls for that matter
in fact the girl
and
you know those are the tiny things you
have to look for maybe you can't just
rush the game and i think you know what
just they're waiting well now he's
played f3 so that's quite interesting
yeah that's a great point uh carl there
if white does castle i think this is a
huge practical mistake because i mean if
i were playing simon for example he
would not hesitate he would throw harry
the h pawn down the board try and open
up this black rook uh towards the white
king and if black gets one more move
throws this ball forward again then it's
exactly what you mentioned there this
white pawn is what we call a hook it
kind of helps black to even open the
position and um yeah i mean this white
king is defenseless it has no defensive
pieces around it
so that i think would be a huge mistake
um giving the address to your opponent
instead just covering squares this is
quite a good strategic move long term
just because now if you look at the
black knight it cannot leap into white's
half of the board um i remember hearing
an interview with hikaru nakamura when
talking about official random chess
chess 960. he said it's nearly always a
mistake to put your knight on the third
rank when it can be dominated by an
opponent's pawn
so this one just takes control of some
squares some territory and as kyle also
mentioned just waiting it's uh it's a
bit of a guessing game if black castles
his king now on this side of the board
on the king side then maybe white feels
safer doing the same because it's less
effective now throwing harry down the
board without a rook uh to kind of
propel it forward and to support it so i
mean you can certainly play harry harold
up the board now if you wanted to if you
wanted to be super aggressive because
with white's last move he has weakened
those dark squares a little bit by
moving a pawn onto the light square so
this idea i think is still if you want
to go super aggressive which i think you
should do against magnus push him go for
it
and balance it and it's very important
to remember that pawns are the only
things that don't move backwards so you
once you've played it you are committed
end off so that has to be played very
carefully is it scary then to play those
moves it's always scary committing
throwing pawns forward and we always
have this kind of uh sparring because
ivanka loves to throw pawns forward i
never want to i never want to commit i
have those big commitments i should ask
you anchorman is it scary
yeah just take a look at it i mean that
pawn is coming forward and uh it's going
to cause a lot of
well i would say worries on the right
side and uh abi manu kind of playing a
little bit calmer he steps back with the
bishop and don't like it what's this
bishop doing here i don't know
white is going to maybe step forward
with the queen i'm not sure which square
white uses the queen for and still this
this kind of dilemma remains white's
gonna kind of keep you guessing which
side you're going on and okay magnus
does play this exact move very logical
maybe at some point hinting that he's
going to push forward in the center but
how does this bishop move help i don't
really understand
yeah maybe this is like showing magnus a
bit too much respect
i remember when i was you know and i am
and i was playing like i remember gwen
jones was playing this tournament and
you could tell he was going to be a real
talent because
a lot of people his age it was quite a
lot younger than me when i was playing
and they get quite scared you know
because i play quite quickly and you
could just tell they gave you far too
much respect and i remember playing gwen
and uh things are starting to go a bit
wrong and i thought okay i'm going to
offer this kid a child just get it over
with you know this child of draw should
i say so i offered him a draw and he
said no no i'm like oh hello
where's my respect and then he went on
to beat me and i thought yeah that's the
way to do it just don't respect your
opponent just go for it and i i think uh
that's the attitude to have you you
gotta like you still gotta respect them
but you gotta be very confident to be a
top player it's that confidence which uh
which obviously helped wayne uh
massively on his way to getting in
thomas and is that what happened uh
because what we're seeing now is i'll be
manu mishra at 13 years old three months
and 15 days and we do have some pictures
of magnus when he was the exact same age
only three days older when he played
kasparov
on march 18
2004 to cause a huge shock to the chess
world because he played great in this
game no respect basically no respect and
i have to say one thing you know gary
kasparov has tremendous presence at the
board you feel that he wants to be you
feel the power and the concentration and
so to
completely dominate the game and kind of
decide that he wanted the draw you know
it was gary who was struggling and uh i
mean that's
takes a lot of
skill and courage
and finally we have harry moving two
squares up the board
a man on the desk simon is gonna be
happy happy happy although is a bit too
late yeah i'm kind of happy but i prefer
moving that pawn when my opponent's king
is the target um and it seems a bit
strange to do that now the white king
has gone the other way it's not a bad
move because you're trying to attack the
pawn structure and uh it makes a lot of
sense uh positionally uh to to play this
move but i would have probably done it a
couple of moves ago yeah could have done
this two three moves ago and white would
have had to answer some serious
questions now it's not really a threat
so a bit strange there but better late
than never simon's story reminded me of
a story about the reverse situation
where it was a kid one of my friends he
was playing against a well-known english
grand master who you know has quite an
authoritative presence
and
the kid was like okay it's going to be a
draw he's going to draw against his
grandmaster so he goes
can i have a go would you like a draw he
goes and
the grandmaster just go let's play kid
and that was it
he was like oh no
some great draw ones i mean i remember
another one i think it was similar as
like a young youngster who's playing
well i don't know if it's the same
english master uh but he he says he says
draw and you know like very quiet and
and the grandmaster just stands up and
goes
where
he looks around the tunnel and then sits
down and gives him evil looks and just
like crushes him so you've got to be
careful offering drawers you know so
yeah or if you do be very confident
going draw
you know do we not think it's a
remarkable thing in chess that we can
just stop at any moment and say draw if
that was football and both teams said
draw and they all walked off
is there another sport that does that
that says let's stop and let's just stop
let's just stop and go off it's true
it's weird
it's just uniquely weird
i don't think they should exist
well exactly exactly it would it would
change the style of chess that people
would play that's for sure dave just
wants to torch people hundreds of movies
how would they the game send in draw
then with those uh 50 moves uh
yeah the repetitions the three move
repetitions
that is kind of a draw agreement though
isn't it it's kind of a draw agreement
yeah so why do we have draw offers
really
i mean in this tour
i think we allow the players are allowed
to offer draws after move 30 after move
40 but we nearly never see them it
always ends up king vs king or it ends
up in a repetition of moves so why have
the draw offers anyway um that's true
and there is a school of thought i don't
know what you think about this but
that in any battle
fewer mistakes are made by the attacking
side
than the defending side now that's worth
thinking about in all the games you've
ever played yeah do you make fewer
mistakes when you're on the front foot
attacking or defending so they say their
best form of defense is attack well why
not front foot in many ways
it might depend on your personality
because i was actually told the reverse
by a very strong ground whilst it's
actually much easier to defend because
there you're just looking at your
opponent's possibility when you're
looking to attack you're feeling this
burden especially if you're giving up
material
me as well you feel like there's burden
there you've got to go forward time is
running out if you don't strike when the
iron is hot that's it
you're gone and you're going to lose the
game so yeah i
don't know but we do like the attacking
games yeah i like the attacking players
and the bar is now over to magnus's side
mishra may be playing a little bit too
respectful in this game so far
yes it feels a bit inconsistent some of
his play i like black's last move just
tucking the king away closer to the
corner just good general kind of chest
wisdom if you castle on the long side
just spend an extra move pushing your
king as close to the corner of the board
as possible it's just safer there
but
somehow it just feels a bit slow mishra
kind of messed around with the black
bishop slightly kind of pushed uh harry
the h pawn forward and then moved his
rook away
it's kind of if you push your h pawn
forward continue pushing it forward or
if you want to centralize your pieces
centralize them but don't waste time on
kind of retreating moves or pawn pushes
or
it just feels like misha is changing
plans on every move and
i mean it's still not a terrible
position for black not that many
weaknesses but white does have the two
bishops white has a slightly more
harmonious pawn structure white is the
one who can push forward in the center
at will whenever he wants
um so mishra
yeah it just feels like a lot of
suffering ahead i don't think there's
anything immediately winning or anything
for white in this position but
simon thoughts on the last few years i
was going to say exactly the same i mean
i i don't think black's position is that
bad at all um but it just seems um a
little bit strange and this is okay
things are going to certainly change now
after magnus pushing aggressively in
center but why play your harold pawn why
then play in the middle and then play on
the other side and then you know you're
kind of just not really doing anything
consistent here but magnus trying to
punish him with this uh i'm surprised he
played this because it is a bit on
magnus like he's normally very patient
and you know will save a push like that
until it's really you know
really only has to you know he's got
nothing else to do but if it works it
works maybe it's just a good move yeah
maybe it's a good move and we have to
jump in and examine it because any time
you push pawns forward exploding open
the center it will come with
consequences as simon mentioned i was
expecting maybe the white bishop to just
step back out of the way
kind of just open up this white rook to
support this pawn in the center and then
only later when you're fully ready then
you push pawns forward but magnus says
okay i didn't need to waste time like
mishra has done over the last few turns
i don't need to waste moves instead
pushes forward and the reason i thought
this was maybe
kind of a bit too risky was because for
example if white takes this pawn let's
say you take back yes white has a very
strong pawn center but suddenly the
black queen can capture this undefended
pawn in the middle of the board and i'm
just trying to figure out what magnus
has in store here
looks like there are some bishop moves
you could
contemplate may be even going up to this
square it looks a bit strange but you
have opened up an attack against the
black queen and suddenly you are hitting
an undefended pawn
wherever the queen goes you can just
take this pawn and
yeah maybe suddenly the white bishops
have come to life this bishop on a great
diagonal hitting this undefended pawn
and this white bishop as well on a bit
of a
kind of annoying square so uh yeah it
could simply be the light square bishop
might just take that pawn immediately
keeping the frets alive as well
keeping a big bishop move uh available
but yeah it's interesting because he you
know he's entering into his
complications which he didn't need to
yeah
that looks very very dangerous and just
moving this bishop at some point with a
discovered attack against the black
queen could well be deadly if you time
it right so
yeah suddenly the stakes are much much
higher and magnus with this pawn push
he's asking mishra to calculate now
mishra has to calculate well just to
survive
because for example if you trade these
pawns if you play a quiet move here as
black
your toast you're done for because at
some point white's going to throw these
pawns forward and
white bishops as we mentioned coming to
life as well it's a
scary position suddenly for mishra and
i'm not sure what i would do to be
honest i would be terrified as black in
the current position do you trade do you
take this one so much choice but as we
showed just a moment ago there are
downsides to every decision you make
all right magnus carlsen coming from
that loss against pragnanda another loss
for magnus against that 16 year old on
the tour and here playing the 13 year
old abhimanyu mishra it does seem that
magnus is
over that loss already he is able to
focus and place on good chess
in this game do you see big winning
opportunities for magnus in this game
yes
i mean he's got the bishop here and we
talk about occupying the center in chess
in any battle i mean carl's been making
those kind of battle analogies
here white is definitely taking the high
ground it's definitely up to measure to
fight back and actually i think in chess
history
okay there's a debate who's the best
player of all time fisher kasparov of
carlson but i think carlson is one of
the best at bouncing back oh yeah he has
faced
many defeats actually in his career but
he's always or nearly always winning the
next game he very rarely loses two in a
row
uh
it's the same with those great former
world champions as well but
yeah carlson's phenomenal kind of
putting those games in the past and
kind of focusing on the person yeah and
talking about casparo and that game in
2004 when sarah magnus made his big mark
on the chess world i guess when he he
did play a draw but he did at some point
dominate i guess that game against
kasparov with the white pieces
abhimanyu mishra yesterday obviously an
online rapid chess but at that very same
age he dominated the game against ding
world number two eventually lost it but
can you somehow compare it a little bit
are we seeing some of that magnus magic
in abu monument definitely that's the
same energy um also i mean when you're
young sometimes you get a bit lucky you
beat players um maybe a bit undeservedly
or you kind of you're on the back foot
for a long time and you just kind of
they blunder and you win because of
their blunder but that's exactly what
magnus has done throughout his career
he's dominated games it's a bit like in
sport controlling possession not
allowing her opponent any chances and
it's rare for a kind of a weaker team to
do that
and yeah in chess
at least mishra yesterday he showed he
can dominate
um this game
it feels like the other way around
unfortunately yeah but it's difficult
with black and of course yeah magnus he
wasn't it wasn't that long ago that he
was a youngster as well so he knows how
to face these uh
young players and okay interesting move
black's knight looks like it's jumped to
a square where it can be taken by a pawn
but white's pawn cannot go and capture
this black knight because the black rook
and the white queen sit on the same line
yeah i think it's gonna move probably
quite a traditional advantage though for
white here as you say i mean this move
is quite flashy uh but i don't think it
really changes much you're not actually
threatening anything um and well again
kyle i think i think you were saying
earlier when you go to prisons you've
got to teach the basics and the center
of the board like a battle is one of the
first things you learn in chess and you
know forget about the openings you know
just control the center and you can do
that from the openings but uh here it's
white center right white's white's got
the center in the middle game and when
you control the center you control the
battlefield and you you generally have
an advantage because you're more
flexible when you use that center and
that's that's where magnus's main
advantage either for
is in this position and the two bishops
of course
yeah and we're just sliding away with
the white queen out of the island of the
black rook so now for example if we see
a trade of knights this is what we call
the ultimate center
oh yeah just supporting everything
replacing pawns with other pawns i
remember from the house how a how-to
video you put up the perfect opening for
white and the pawns isn't that exact
position yeah um as i say that i'm not
sure which way magnus will take back
humans take it with a it also has a lot
to say for it but yeah either way the
ideal center for example if black trades
yeah as you mentioned there kai pawns
supported by pieces
that's the key and these bishops have a
lot of potential to break down long term
against the black pawns and also
supported by those rooks behind them i
mean this looks to me like beginner
level this looks so good for white
and it is it is good and it's just a sim
simply an easier position for white to
play i mean like you say the rooks are
very nicely positioned in the center
they also because white controls the
center have the potential just to go to
the right go to the left they have that
flexibility and sometimes it's just now
simply about making those small
improving moves and just continuously
asking abby man you like what are you
going to do next i'm just slowly
improving it's up to you to come up with
a move and it's not easy to even find a
plan for black interesting from magnus
there just taking a timeout pushing this
pawn he's created a safe square for his
king if necessary long term if things
get complicated it's an escape square
and yeah as ivanka says i mean it's so
hard to find a move for black is the
kind of move isn't it david a3 which i i
think is just a sign of a very strong
player because i think if you're you
know you're you're starting out in chess
you're always trying to force the issue
as your banker said as well you're
trying to try to do something you know
try and do something but the sign of a
real top player is understanding you
control the position you play and move
like a friend you're basically saying to
your opponent it's just like what are
you doing you know i'm complete control
i'm sure i'm playing with my food you
know i'm just gonna roll it about my
mouth a little bit before i eat it
you're my food i'm just going to wait
until you make a mistake and uh yeah
that's a bit of a analogy
let's not picture that too much
about chess about knowing when to hold
and when to push it's really important
in a general sense because
many people myself included have lost
games that we could easily have held if
we just waited sit back wait to move no
we have to go for it don't we too
compulsive know when to wait no when to
go
it's like kenny rogers
again you're going to know when somebody
could go and look at the abbey
monument's t-shirt oh morphe yeah
very famous american chess player never
a world champion i'd love to see he
would have they weren't world champions
at that time
so he would have probably would have
been he's by far the strongest player i
want to see can we get magnus to wear
like a picture of david on his t-shirt
well i'd love to see that you know
magnus just takes his jumper off and
there's david howe
that's got to be a challenge careful
what you wish for
i want to see that now let's make that
happen
yeah oh wow i'm inspired by paul morphy
i'll be monie mishra maybe but uh
struggling in this game wow there's been
a few changes actually okay in this
position because abby manuel you know he
didn't sit and wait he was like well let
me challenge the white pawn center
and i was a little bit surprised to see
magnus actually capture that pawn
and
now yes
those pawns look weak on the right side
but at the same time they have the
potential to generate some dynamic play
and uh at least the black knight is no
longer a dead piece black's knight can
jump into the center of the board to the
d5 square later
it does have potential
to really play a role uh on an outpost
but first magnus is going for those weak
black pawns and this is the type of
position where okay suddenly the
computer surprisingly says black is
completely fine but
if he's not accurate black might just
lose a pawn lose another pawn um those
black f and h pawns are terminally weak
almost
so yeah i
i still think mishra is up against it
okay it's uh
a decision whether to trade a set of
rooks maybe whether to just jump into
the center with the black knight
does he leave those black pawns just let
them drop or does he go on the defensive
uh go a bit passive maybe trying to
defend them if he drops into the center
with that knight onto d5 attacking the
bishop on c3
would you
keep the bishop or would you let him
take the knight take the bishop
very good question
for example if white gets greedy and
takes this black pawn yes white goes a
pawn up but um after allowing this trade
suddenly the white king is a bit open
suddenly these pawns on dart squares
might be vulnerable to the black dart
squad bishop you can imagine the bishop
coming this way to attack a pawn or
maybe this way to attack and porn so
yeah i would be reluctant somehow as
white yes you've won a porn but you lose
control um so i think the other option
you mentioned there carl um
just maybe stay taking a step back with
a bishop that would be
maybe the first option that comes to my
mind
and also this bishop does kind of keep
this knight
under check
there's nowhere this knight can jump
forward to
right now there are other options for
example do you trade rooks and then
trade off this night just to get greedy
and maybe win a pawn at the end for
example rook takes rook and maybe taking
this knight off the board but magnus
won't want to go for trades that allow
the black pieces to get active
the black rook now may be on an open
line
so yeah i think uh this is just logical
from both sides why not jump into the
center if you can okay first he trades
rooks is the intention now uh next move
to jump into the middle of the board
with the black knight
and maybe i'm being too hasty uh
deciding that the white rook needs to
capture the black rook maybe magnus will
drop back with his bishop just so that
it's out of the range of that black
knight as we mentioned so if the black
knight jumps in now you don't have to
take a move removing your bishop from
its eye line
you can now just go and grab a pawn
really interesting moment just that's i
mean the mark of another a really top
level player in this position i would
just say okay my opponent's taking my
work i want my rook on the open file i
want to bring it forward later but
magnus he looks for all the options in
the current position bishop takes also
is very logical huh interesting and well
abhimani mishra he has take down two
three minutes on the clock and he takes
it with a bishop yeah um just the fact
that he took a few seconds there made me
think oh actually my instinct was maybe
just a bit too hasty here
yeah i like that move for white we want
to keep bishops on an open board
otherwise
i've i thought we should set up a
helpline for people who have you know
calling and saying excuse me i'm a chess
player and i've got two bishops on an
open board and i'll have exchange one
off for a night and they say oh dear
well let me just put you in touch with
the gm they'll talk you through it we
have a meeting every wednesday
don't be giving up bishops on an open
ball
in general i'll join that meeting every
wednesday
i've been there
bishops are long range pieces so having
a bishop even retreating a bishop to the
first rank is not such a bad thing um
okay
uh mishra he knew one of his pawns was
doomed so he threw it forward and now
two harrys are better than one right
simon white has two h pawns that's what
they say yeah or harry harry and harold
that's right is that a situation where
the double pawns is a good
situation it's an extra pawn so i guess
it is probably okay but still sometimes
double pawns can be good normally in the
center of the board where you can
control a lot of squares but i think the
main point here is that's a pass pawn so
in the ending it could become a queen
because there's nothing obstructing it
uh
black pushes his past pawn forward he's
created a passport of his own
like porn i really like what i mean manu
has done actually you know you don't
like this last move though oh you don't
like that bishop i don't really
understand
i guess it's tempting to push a pawn
especially a past one now white has a
permanent blockade on the light squares
that's true that's very true
but uh yeah and both pawns are motoring
forward
i have to say the black king it looks
very safe though with all those uh
pieces and pawns around it yeah i think
both kings are pretty safe right now
white's king potentially a bit
vulnerable but it can just shuffle off
into the corner if it really needs to
first mishra trying to activate his
knight
i think that's the number one priority
but yeah he's done
good work with his king the black safe
as houses
in the near future at least
so there is a question for magnus how to
break through will it be all about the
uh harold porn that we named it today i
think so i mean it's that porn is just
simply going to try and tie down black
surf forces especially like rock if
possible
and the kind of move that you kind of
want to play is you want to push that
pawn forward and relocate the bishop to
a better diagonal but for the time being
you can't really touch the pieces on the
light squares instead you have to focus
on improving the dark squared push up
yeah white's darts got a bishop at the
bottom of the board i said they're great
long-range pieces but here should really
improve itself
i think magnus just deciding where to
put that piece we're expecting white's
bishop on e1 just to make a decision it
can go in either direction
i'd have to say i really love seeing
abby man you play i love the way he pops
up and down i mean
this just gives it away that he is 13
years old energy
you know his play over the board that's
older that's like a really you know very
experienced grand master but uh
the online behavior is like he's like a
hummingbird on steroids isn't he
brilliant brilliant he's bouncy isn't he
he is
yeah i just wish that he'd put the angry
bird cushion as well in her eye line so
they would just
add that extra point to magnus you're
playing against the kid
it was but we did ask him yesterday
about the spider-man cushion he didn't
quite know where he was they painted the
house or something like that but i have
to say since last year when he played
chessable monsters he has grown up a lot
there's a big difference between 12 and
13. he looks older
he acts older i guess he plays older his
voice is broken yeah yeah i mean last
year on the tour um what he did playing
the chessboard masters he won that one
game but even that one game he won was
very shaky very up and down but um okay
he had a few tough defeats there as well
but this tournament even though he's had
two losses already um yeah he's
definitely controlling things more so
the maturity levels of his play
are a different level yeah vastly
different level he's made good work of
the last 12 months it must be fun to be
a young chess player because so much
happens in such a short period of time
whereas at the age you guys are now
maybe
[Laughter]
it would be lovely to be like 13 again
obviously once you sort of know
well everyone makes mistakes don't they
as well and it's like but you're also
you know just enjoying
the fact that you're playing the world
champs and everything's nice and you're
excitable and everything's good yeah
exactly yeah but the buzzing all in in
the normal club
chess world is that just
how many of these youngsters are coming
through there's like a new name every
week and they're massively strong you
couldn't be this strong before no
computers help but you have to have
latent talent and i wish that they could
invent chess spectacles i nearly called
them chesticles but that's probably bad
that i could just put on and see what
you see and go you know in the matrix
when they go when he when he has this
thing he says i can do kung fu just put
those on and go i can do chess
you put some on there if i can see what
he sees just for give me 10 minutes
it'll be fantastic
stock fish
a lot of people do that that's true
too many people do that online
unfortunately
yeah but look at that look at that
intense look i mean that's frightening
that that's that's
really really off-putty yeah i'm sure he
doesn't mean it but he just has that
fixed glaze yeah yeah i think magnus for
sure won't have the webcam open you
don't want to get stared down
looking that angry that's the kind of
look my wife susan has when i ask her to
pay the bill
hopefully she is watching she is she is
watching
she's watching whilst preparing jubilee
celebrations i think as they all are in
the uk oh the queen so villages
everywhere we'll be having cake and
bunting
and i'm having one in my village but
taking a chest table a chess set and
getting the opportunity for more people
to play taking some prisoners
should i say then happy jubilee day is
it how do you it's it's in june oh okay
so it's not yet it's like preparations
though yeah we'll remember yeah all
right we do have some moves and magnus
did decide which way to go with his
bishop yeah and i really like what
mishra has done on the last move at
least i think it was a very necessary
decision to jump in with black knight
and there has been a trade so let's
check out what's happened and okay
magnus not getting greedy and allowing a
pawn to survive so if we backtrack just
one move uh we see that in this position
black's knight yes it's on a great
outpost but it's not really affecting
play you need to get rid of white's
bishop pair that is the number one
priority the longer the game goes on the
more powerful they'll become so black's
knight jumped in and after white took it
it's just too strong to
allow it to survive suddenly a trap well
a positional trap at least if white
takes this very far advanced black pawn
then suddenly black will jump forward
with a track and pick off one of white's
h pawns so for example if the white king
moves one h pawn drops and the other h
pawn as well a big big target
attacked by the black queen and by the
black bishop and suddenly half the board
has just been kind of wiped out and i
think we would have been heading towards
a draw also note opposite color bishops
which we saw earlier today having a very
george tendency so opposite colour
bishop's still on the board but magnus
dodged that small trap he didn't take
this black pawn instead he brought his
bishop back and
yes now white can keep this pawn alive
maybe push it forward but at least
mishra has his own uh kind of strength
to bank on this black pawn
maybe will act as a distraction it's
going to be very annoying
at least for magnus over the next few
moves so still roughly in the balance
mishra is fighting back after a very
difficult position
david 15 seconds is that right wow okay
let's go back to the players actually
because the clock is going to play a big
big factor
uh magnus only at one and a half minutes
as well so yeah anything could still
happen mishra improving the black bishop
i think it could be this h pawn though
the h pawn looks so far advancing i
think if you move it two squares it's
defended by the bishop and here it goes
yeah running so strong that pawn uh
surprised he allowed it to push on i
thought maybe try and keep it under lock
and key maybe just keep an eye on it
with the black rook or the black queen
but now this white pawn
squares away
and it could okay you've got to try to
guard it with the bishop the bishop does
control the queening square of white's
pawn but the bishop is also very loose
there it's in a pin there could be some
nasty tactics like queen check and
everything it gets traded off so for
example here there's just a fret i i
don't know if white you know if it's
white yeah um if black just takes the
time out pushes a pawn uh okay he pushes
this pawn that's important but then
check as simon says
and maybe giving up pieces just to try
and promote you can take the pawn with
with your queen you have a tactic on the
board another trick yeah yeah and a very
strong position as ivanka mentions this
is okay it has just happened queen takes
pawn is not a blunder it's not a mouse
slip if the white queen is taken then
white can recapture the black queen and
this rook now cannot actually go and
grab the white rook because it has to
keep an eye on this corner square it has
to keep an eye on the white pawn
so rook takes rook would allow white a
new queen let's go back to the game we
saw black's queen try and dodge and now
a queen trade imminent and
okay the queen trade is about to happen
measure down to five seconds though
and okay that was a check black's queen
blocked
oh that white pawn though it's surely
gonna win the game now for magnus that
white pawn harry yeah definitely he's
done the job yeah it's uh i mean i can
see so many ways that for instance the
the white bishop can actually relocate
itself
to the g8 square and then you can get
rid of the bishop maybe you can do that
immediately ivanka maybe you can go
bishop in front of the king and then
over there you know bishop b3 yeah
that's what i was thinking yeah that's a
good idea i think that it looks strong
there's several ways for magnus to win
but his camera has frozen
has he been disconnected magnus spending
30 seconds on this one move dear he's
low on time he's under one minute now
magnus okay he's back on the camera um
there's plenty of winning moves here for
white you could just take off the queens
if you want trade off the queens we can
even go with your queen straight over to
the g8 square go with the white queen
all the way up to the top of the board
try and
kind of block off black's rook okay the
white bishop though is going to act as
the blockader it's going to go up to g8
and look at this this is going to lock
in that black rook into the corner
i love it does well i'll pretend to play
rook takes bishop here to show off
i don't know this move is
very visual i like these visual little
things where the rook is trapped and
we've been talking about chess and
prisons that black rook is a prisoner
now right it can never get out
and
it's uh yeah it's uphill now for mishra
magnus just needs to trade queens bring
the white king in it's almost as if that
black rook and the white bishop don't
exist and you can just look at the rest
of the board count the rest of the
pieces he's played this move this this
this looked like a very pretty way of
winning with the white king running in
eventually in the ending yeah so white's
actually down on material right now
but white is completely winning because
that black rook is caged in
and yeah the black pawn in the middle is
going to drop sooner or later
like you're kind of saying it's like
they don't exist this is true it
certainly is it's actually better than
not existing for white because that
white bishop takes away some squares
from the black king white's bishop
actually plays an active part black's
rook is a passive actually having the
extra the extra h pawn helps a lot here
because you can uh you can use that to
save time at the right case and black's
probably gonna run out of moves as as
he's gonna what is sort of the winning i
mean if it went all the way to checkmate
what would bees or the winning plan for
magnus now that he cannot
move that pawn to the queening square so
at some point he's going to use his king
he's going to bring it over and win
black's rook and we're going to reach a
position already that's what uh that's
called zugzwang that means any move
black makes will worsen his own position
and look at the black king it's
completely stuck defending black's pawn
in the middle of the board
sooner or later black's running out of
moves there's nothing else to do black's
king is gonna have to give way and white
will just use his king take the black
horn in the center
and start darting towards the black rook
but does he need to take that black pawn
before he starts running forwards yes
he'll wait until black runs out of moves
he'll take that black pawn in the center
and then the white king will go
towards that black rogue it's game over
there we go
had to move and mishra is trying to
adopt a formation we call the opposition
where black's king blocks off white's
king from moving forward but again as
simon said white can wait sooner or
later with this pawn
that is a very useful pawn we talked
about
those two harry potters this one is
actually doing the winning uh and is it
now swang already or are we gonna be it
will be in the next move
so
any move that abby manu makes will just
worsen his position he would just
actually like just to go pass yeah
unfortunately you can't do that in jazz
and uh yeah i think we'll see a result
any moment just uh we'll explain it
maybe in more detail a bit later but the
black king is going to have to give way
no matter which way the black king goes
the white king will go the opposite way
and trader pawns will not help black
here we go the white king is coming in
now
and yeah
max king
unable to help
it's getting close then i guess a win
for magnus carlsen striking back after
losing to prague in uh round five
mishra giving it a good go but of course
facing the world champion
it will be hard for a 13 year old
and we saw a quick flurry of moves there
white king did grab the remaining black
pawn
and
it's not only one pawn that black has to
deal with now all of those white pawns
are pushing forward
and you can tell on the body language
magnus knows it's winning and mishra
gives up
it's over a win for calls and striking
back